sur le président mes chers collègues
madame la ministre
la réorganisation éventuel du groupe edf
par le projet recul élaboré par sa
direction à la demande du gouvernement
ne manque pas d'interroger sur le fond
tout d'abord force est de constater que
l'objectif recherché initialement avec
la mise en place de la reine est loin
d'avoir été atteint
imposer à edf de réserver à ses
concurrents français et européens
une partie de sa production nucléaire à
un prix fixe de 42 euros par mégawatt
heure qui n'a maintenant plus bougé
depuis dix ans suscite des
interrogations
le bénéfice annoncé pour le consommateur
sous prétexte de concurrence accrue est
en réalité inexistant avec un prix de
l'électricité sans cesse croissant au
point que la précarité énergétique
auparavant un épiphénomène en france est
aujourd'hui une réalité grandissante de
notre côté de multiples fournisseurs
alternatifs qu'ils ne produisent pas un
kilowattheure d'électricité boursicote
au gré des prix de gros et se
fournissent chez edf
chaque fois que c'est à leur avantage je
comprends donc que l'état négocie
âprement avec bruxelles
pour remédier à cette situation ubuesque
qui met à mal notre champion mondial de
l'électricité pour autant le projet
hercules visant à séparer le groupe edf
en trois entités m'interpelle que l'état
souhaite conserver dans le giron de
nationale 1 et df bleus gérant le
nucléaire énergie qui a permis à la
france de bénéficier depuis des
décennies de l'électricité la moins
chère d'europe
cela me paraît indispensable et je
souscris pleinement à cette approche
stratégique qu'il en aille de même pour
rené df azur dédié à la produit à la
production hydroélectrique de nos grands
barrages j'y souscris également sous
réserve néanmoins que les autres
exploitants déjà en place en france
comme la chaîne dans les pyrénées voient
également leur intérêt préserver en
revanche l'ouverture à des capitaux
privés d'une filiale dite verte dédiée
aux activités de fourniture
d'électricité aux particuliers aux
entreprises au développement des nerfs
et surtout à la distribution
d'électricité
me paraît plus que hasardeuse sur la
fourniture d'électricité
ce projet acterait la fin des tarifs
réglementés en france ce qui ne me
paraît pas satisfaisant pour les abonnés
concernés
au vu de la situation économique des
prochaines années sur les énergies
renouvelables
je m'inquiète également que l'appât du
gain lié à la promotion du grand t au
lien offshore puissent relayer au second
rang la production d'énergies
renouvelables photovoltaïque ou issus de
la biomasse solution qui valorisent nos
territoires
mais surtout je suis indigné à l'idée
que le réseau de distribution électrique
qui appartient aux collectivités locales
à nos communes et qui a simplement été
concédée à une église puisse dépendre
des desiderata d'investisseurs privés
cette hypothèse me laisse sans voix
investir sur le réseau électrique est
une nécessité
ce n'est pas une option les coupures
d'électricité liées aux intempéries
nous le rappellent régulièrement
j'ajoute que la péréquation nationale
issue du turpe est la seule garante d'un
service public de qualité y compris en
zone rurale le principe d'égalité des
usagers du service public en dépend
aussi pourquoi vouloir remettre en
question un système électrique national
qui a fait ses preuves au risque de
transformer avec le projet recul le
groupe et df en un colosse aux pieds
d'argile
il sur la forme maintenant pouvez vous
me confirmer madame la ministre comme
projet de loi sera bien présenté au
parlement sur ce sujet comme vous nous
l'aviez annoncé ici au sénat lors d'une
audition au mois de novembre dernier
je vous remets